please welcome Joe and bones
[Applause]
[Music]
welcomewelcome scanning in yet alright
this is a wonderful show I mean I'm in
culture shock in the States a long
segment is four and a half minutes
maximum oh well we have a lot of time
what I saw these pictures it's it's I
mean this brings back memories for many
but but how is it for you to see the
pictures from back in the days who were
you then
it's hard to think of that young person
is me now
I appreciate watching her and what she
did and there was just I just see a
gifted young woman who had already
decided to do what her life what she did
you know take the voice and use it for
social change and doing as much good as
I could have you have you changed I mean
a lot of your views are still the same
but have you changed as a person I think
if you reach my age which is 77 and
don't think you've changed at all then
you're really delusional so I'm sure I
have but I would say that the foundation
in my life which really was non-violence
and nonviolent action attempt to live a
non-violent life that stayed the same
I'm not saying I have but I'm saying
that's know that's what one tries to do
that stayed the same through thick and
thin and and Here I am you you people
called you very day you had this very
serious image oh god I know
[Laughter]
I mean being becoming famous I mean
quite quite overnight in a way as a very
young person is did you deal well with
that did the deal went well with Fame
during the years I mean what I did it
was I went overboard I didn't want to be
commercial I didn't want to ride around
in limousines I didn't want to have
anything to do with Hollywood so I went
the other direction which is probably
just as
bigger bore because to keep me happy the
stage had to be pitch black no Flags no
flowers you know and somebody commented
what she's just as difficult as having a
rock band because at least they had some
freedom to try and make that place look
nice but I'm glad that I chose the
direction I did because I probably would
get lost and the way the way a lot of
young people do or people do and that
sparkling world of nonsense do you think
that in in in general that you could be
a difficult person to work with I would
probably have to ask the people who work
with me but right now I'm not so bad
yeah what we saw a clip here with Bob
Dylan and you you you were very
important in his career you you gave him
onions and you performed it all together
could he be difficult to work with that
dessert that's an even bigger laughter I
think's right I'm trying to say that we
don't know you are so inevitable talk
about Bob so I just want to say that I
appreciate him I care about him recently
he said some really nice things about me
no and that time period with him and the
other very gifted people 60s and 70s is
something that will never happen again
it was some kind of explosion of talent
and gifts and and then that many more
people wanting to be engaged in some
kind of action either civil rights or
against the war in Vietnam and so people
now are longing for that feeling and I
have to say that the closest thing to
that feeling that's happened since then
is happening right now with the students
in Florida it you get the feeling that a
real movement is gonna build out of this
which is fascinating here these 15 year
old kids standing at the microphone
saying yeah we're not gonna accept this
anymore we're not going to accept the
NRA and then you see National Rifle
Association then you see Delta Air Lines
and Hertz rent-a-car saying they're
gonna pull distance themselves from the
National Right Rifle Association well
that's never happened if it took this
little bunch of kids and they seemed
dead serious about it this is I mean
you're gonna do a very relevant song for
us a little later about about this topic
in a way yeah but I wonder because you
you I mean you've been an activist for
so long you even marched with Martin
Luther King and you've been very
influential to people from different
worlds like like I mean Bob Dylan I
mentioned Martin Luther King and and you
were even with Steve Jobs the founder
Apple so different they are so
influential these people and they were
influenced by you as well do you see
these people have anything in common
that you can recognize they're all
complicated they're all common I had an
interview with I think she was an
Australian journalist over the phone
long distance had a lot of questions a
lot of answers and she said I have one
last question and I said sure and she
said do you realize you the only woman
in the world has seen both Bob Dylan and
Steve Jobs naked and I said at the same
time are you comfortable with the term
protest singer if people I mean they're
worse things but that's not how I've
considered what I've done I mean they're
very I think a protest song is more
about the context of where you're
singing it and then
about the words of the song I mean for
instance when my ex-husband was in
prison for draft resistance his me what
he loved best was Merle Haggard and
country-western songs so I would say I'm
dedicating this to my husband who is
blah blah blah and explained about the
war and so on and then then I'd sing
country-and-western song so you couldn't
it was far from a protest song as you
could get button used in that context
that that's you you I mean you've done
more than done singing performing and
I'm talking you actually you traveled a
lot and you traveled into war zones we
were telling Forrest story here yeah I
know that you were in back in 72 you
were in Hanoi when the bombs fell really
hard mm-hmm can you take us back there
for a moment well when I went it was as
a peace group to meet with a peace group
in Hanoi where they were no North
Vietnamese Communist Party but wanted to
talk you know just to talk and we went
over there was a minister and a Maoist
kid is a little you know a left-wing
ex-military and four-star general with
us
and we got there and all I can remember
is the beginning there had not been any
bombing there for half a year so nobody
was expecting the sound of this siren
went off at our second night second big
dinner you know welcoming us and the
siren went off and I'm thinking over
they must have these exercises all the
time then we heard boom boom in the
distance and you know for us we didn't
know what was happening really the
Vietnamese did but they were stunned but
they got us down in bomb shelter and I
remember in the bomb shelter that's
where I understood about my own
mortality I mean I kind of was so
frightened and a lot of times I'm not
frightened they do this stuff and if
they come you get very calm but you
can't be calming that atheists agnostics
everybody saying dear God please don't
let that bomb land on me No
then afterward you feel guilty because
it fell on somebody else I mean it's not
a win-win situation it was it was pretty
terrible I had a moment when I decided
this pacifist is not going to run to the
bomb shelter and so the next time the
siren went off I just walking very
slowly
there was explosion really really near
and everybody started running and I ran
so fast whether I just lost all my
brilliant self image I had I just
trampled people trying to get to the
bomb shelter did you feel like you could
comfort people or did people have to
comfort you
as soon as I got soon as I was a veteran
which took one night they had eleven
bomb raids in one night then I'd sang
I'd sing in the shelter in the yeah and
it probably calmed me to do that very a
very different venue indeed yes we are
you're gonna do a song for us and I know
you're very concerned about your voice
mm-hmm what what what's happening with
your voice it's um like everybody else
who sings the gravity starts taking over
pretty soon it'll take over everything
but for me it's mostly starting the
throat it's the muscle in there and it
loses flexibility and you have to start
working with it
the song you're gonna do it's it's a
song that's very relevant today yeah you
just kind of drop out of the sky when I
was putting this album together it's
called the president sang Amazing Grace
and it's about the time that Obama sang
Amazing Grace after the killings
the school in Charleston and he I mean
no other president could have done that
and I hope none of ever tries because he
was this wonderful black man surrounded
by you know black people in the church
the song says there were no words to say
and apparently there weren't because he
leaned into the microphone and he
started singing Amazing Grace and is one
of the most moving things I'd ever seen
and then this young woman wrote a song
wrote this song about it
so you're gonna wear this thing I'm
gonna wear these little and your fingers
fix it okay well this one you stick
under your nail so you can go like that
and you can go like that it's amazing
you can do both ways there you go let me
just see how to
you ready yes I'm ready
joan baez thank you hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe